and one of the things that I thought
that's always weird is the um you know
the a lot of conspiracy theories get
demonized
um and suppressed but then the whole
Flat Earth conspiracy theory was seemed
to be amazingly promoted
um and so it's just uh made me think
it's you know less valuable because no
one's trying to suppress it it was so
ridiculous that nobody wanted bothered
to suppress it
um yeah it's an odd one because it you
can demonstrate to yourself that the
Earth can't be flat
um so I I do wonder why it suddenly
showed up but
but nonetheless
um you know
here we are on a very round earth
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure of
sitting today with Ramsey rammerman who
is a an attorney with 20 years
experience on First Amendment and open
government issues Ramsay welcome to
Darkhorse thank you
so you uh and I have been in
conversation for I don't know how long
about issues surrounding section 230 of
the communication is decency Act is that
yeah is that what it is
um this is an Arcane piece of
legislation that turns out to be at the
core of what I swear is the dysfunction
of Civilization now we have our
our work cut out for us here in the
sense that one of the ways that
skullduggery protects itself is to be so
deathly boring that nobody can pay
attention long enough to figure out how
it works so our job here is to figure
out how to reveal to the Dark Horse
audience what section 230 is what effect
it's having on the world what its
authors intended how that's different
from what has unfolded and that's not
going to be easy to do in a way that is
um that is
cultivating of attention so if I can ask
you a favor if you could
um sprinkle into your explanations a
certain number of curse words and when
you use analogies please make them
sexual that will keep people uh on track
very good that's not very fitting in
this context yes perfect all right so
Ramsay tell us what section 230 of the
communications decency Act is
so it's a statute that it impacts the
liability of social media companies for
the speech that they carry
um which as in social medias you know is
the speech of third parties
and it was enacted in 1996 to address
um problems in the law
um as it existed before it was enacted
on when a third party could be liable
for somebody else's speech
I see so
1996 is substantially before the social
media era
um the the internet was digital by that
point but um it still uh was a um a
crude prototype of what we have now so
of course the authors of this section
couldn't really Envision things like
Twitter and Facebook and the way their
uh their Amendment might might impact us
what problem were they trying to solve
they were trying to deal with the
problems of message boards
and so the um the two cases that that
dealt with this were uh cubby versus
CompuServe you may remember CompuServe
sure and then uh Stratton Oakmont versus
Prodigy Services these were two cases
dealing with message boards and
um the the premise or the issue of
liable liability for third-party speech
is the same with the message board as it
would eventually be with social media in
that you have someone hosting speech but
the speech is made by Third parties and
the host has a certain level of control
or lack of control over what speech gets
posted and so these two cases dealt with
when when the message board be liable
for post by a third party
so this is interesting to me as a kid I
was involved in what were called message
boards they were a crude prototype of
what eventually became services like
CompuServe in our book Heather and I
discussed the danger of hyper novelty
which is making modern people sick both
physically and psychologically
two of the most common disorders are
anxiety and depression our first sponsor
mind Bloom is a leader in the treatment
of anxiety and depression using at-home
ketamine therapy it is a combination of
science-backed Medicine with clinician
guidance and support for people looking
to improve mental health and increase
their sense of well-being
mind Bloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric professionals to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin take mind Bloom's online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you if
approved you'll discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen
mindbloom will send you a kit in the
mail complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience
after only two sessions 87 percent of
Mind Bloom clients reported improvements
in depression and 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety
it's time to enter the next chapter in
mental health and well-being let mind
Bloom guide you
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com
Darkhorse and use the promo code
Darkhorse at checkout
go to mindbloom.com Darkhorse use the
promo code Darkhorse for a hundred
dollars off your first succession
program today that's mindbloom.com Dark
Horse and use the promo code Darkhorse
at checkout our second sponsor for this
episode is American Hartford gold
inflation is at its highest level in 40
years we all feel it at the grocery
store on a fuel pump interest rates are
soaring retirement accounts are in real
Danger
if you want to better protect your
family's future you should consider that
people have been putting wealth into
precious metals for thousands of years
the more uncertain access to other
stores of value gets the more precious
precious metals are likely to become
call American Hartford gold to see how
easy it is to get started
they can show you how to protect your
savings and retirement account by
diversifying your portfolio with
physical gold and silver composed of
actual atoms
all it takes to get started is a short
phone call and they'll have physical
gold and silver delivered right to your
door or inside your IRA or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients
call them now they will give you a
percentage of your first qualifying
order back in free silver
call American Hartford gold at
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to
998899 again that's 866-828-1117
or text Darkhorse to
998899 you know I remember dial-up
message boards where there was literally
a phone number that connected to
somebody's computer in their house that
they had set up as a board to discuss
uh whatever it might be you know whether
you know back then
we were talking about things like how to
hack the copy protection on software
kids would exchange games and other
programs and you know they would uh
essentially violate the rights of the
the intellectual property owners by
exchanging information on how to how to
defeat the copy protection so that sort
of thing existed there and I can
certainly imagine
um in the context of dial-up message
boards there was
stuff on there that was really marginal
right and it was it was the wild west
and you can certainly imagine
the instinct to protect this environment
because there was really no way for
somebody who set up this service which
was a good thing you know what you
discussed on it wasn't necessarily good
but the idea that somebody would use
their own computer to facilitate the
interaction of people who lived hundreds
of thousands of miles away from each
other was a positive thing but it wasn't
going to be possible if you know any
psychopath could post any criminal
material on there and uh cause the
person who simply supplied the computer
technology to be liable so is that the
problem that was being addressed that is
the problem that was being addressed and
I think to understand how it or why it
became a problem it would be useful to
talk about
um how third party liability worked
before the computer age because the
rules were developed pre-computer and
that's kind of where there became a
problem here so
prior to the computer age we had the
liability for third parties was broken
into two categories you had publisher
liability and distributor liability
and so Publishers were deemed to be just
as liable for defamation and other
speech-based torts as the speaker exact
same liability and the theory being that
the publisher has editorial discretion
on choosing what they publish and then
changing the words and therefore it's
fair to make the publisher compliable
for to the same expense extent as the
speaker
when you have Distributors Distributors
would be like a bookstore or a library
or a shipping company that ships books
and for Distributors the law developed
that they were only liable if they had
actual knowledge or constructive
knowledge of the tortious nature of the
speech and for defamation it's really
hard for a distributor to be liable
because you have to say they know it's
actually defamation and abs in a court
finding that it's defamation that's very
hard but the same rules applied for
obscenity and so just the case law
dealing with Distributors were basically
did they know what they were you know
Distributing qualified as obscene and
you can imagine given the you know
covers of those type of magazines or the
such there may be at least constructive
knowledge a duty to figure out if it's
obscene
um but they had to have actual knowledge
and the the distributor is treated
differently because they can't change
the content so as far as defamation they
aren't they don't have any ability to
edit it and so they were only liable if
they had actual knowledge and so when
the first case came up the cubby versus
compute case came up they're The Message
Board um there was no editorial
um to scratch no edit the host did not
exercise any editorial Authority
whatever got posted got posted
and so there the court looked at it and
said okay this message board is like a
distributor because you aren't
exercising any editorial Authority
that was in 1992 or 1991 sorry and then
um the second case the um Stratton
Oakmont case versus Prodigy was
1995. and there by then the The Prodigy
had learned that you can't have complete
free reign on it you have to exercise
some limits on editorial so they had
some basic rules
um of you know like no profanity no
pornography or whatever and you know
um certain limitations and they
exercised very limited editorial
Authority and so when they were sued
they said you should treat us just like
CompuServe because we're having very
minimal editorial Authority it's preset
rules
um we aren't trying to change you know
viewpoints we're just trying to you know
keep certain garbage off our listener
and the court said no
um the the essence of a publisher is the
exercise of editorial Authority and if
you exercise any editorial Authority
we're going to treat you like a
publisher not a distributor ah which
creates a terrible bind then because
there's obviously stuff that you have to
be able to keep off of a service and
then as soon as you've done that minimal
work you have made yourself uh you have
opened yourself to the possibility of
liability suits over things like
defamation exactly and so
um that was in 1995 and then at that
time the communications decency Act was
already in the works and um this part
section 230 gets added to that to
address that problem
and so um I think that it's so that's
the basic defamation law I think one
other
um foundational
um aspect that's important to understand
is
um the First Amendment concepts of
Association and Viewpoint discrimination
and so
um
under the First Amendment there's the
five you know explicit rights the
religion speech press assembly petition
but there's also a sixth right the
courts have recognized which is the
right of Association
and so this is something that came out
each of the five explicit rights have an
associate associational aspect but the
courts have recognized that this right
of Association is an independent First
Amendment right
and as the right of Association it also
includes obviously the right not to
associate
just like the right to speech includes
the right not to speak
and so that's one fundamental principles
understanding the right of Association
the second aspect is
um understanding the levels of
censorship there's
we have
um
content neutral
censorship rules these are generally
time place and Mana rules things like
you can't have music played at a certain
volume after a certain time of day they
don't depend anything on the content
it's just the volume but they obviously
impact speech
then you have a Content based but
Viewpoint neutral limitations these are
limitations that may impact what speech
is being made but don't turn on the
Viewpoint being expressed they're going
to be neutral rules
and then you have Viewpoint based and
Viewpoint based is obviously as it
sounds
um it's uh you're censoring People based
on the Viewpoint they're expressing and
Viewpoint censorship is almost always
unconstitutional very limited
circumstances has to meet the highest
level of of Court scrutiny to to be
permitted and it's almost always
prohibited although those same
um the Viewpoint is also plays a role in
the right to Association you can have
limitations on Association if their
content neutral if they aren't Viewpoint
neutral they're not based on the
Viewpoint or the Viewpoint based and so
non-discrimination laws generally are
considered Viewpoint neutral and they
obviously Force Association but they
they can be applied in situations where
the association is not aimed at
expressing some point of view and so
that's why a restaurant you can force a
restaurant to associate with customers
with non-discrimination laws
um but if the association is there for
the purpose of expressing a Viewpoint
then then certain limitations end up
being Viewpoint based and that's why for
example in religious organizations
people who play a spiritual role in
those religious organizations are not
subject to discrimination laws
because the ideas that you know
something in that religion may have
impact like if you don't want women to
be priests that's based on a spiritual
basis and therefore you can do that in
some non-discrimination laws don't apply
to those type of positions
yes
in in these well maybe I should let you
uh get where you were going
well I'm just I can I can almost feel us
losing in the various intricacies you
are describing I understand why they're
important the law has to be
um precise uh and it has to allow for
all of the important things and allow
the prohibiting of the things that are
truly troubling and the difficulty is in
doing these things in such a way that
you know especially in the context of an
unfolding technology that you don't end
up with massive unintended consequences
which is exactly where we are right
you're talking about laws that emerged
as the world went from dial up uh
bulletin boards to services like
CompuServe and Prodigy and then the
question is okay so you make a rule that
protects CompuServe and strategy in
those in that context and then what
happens when the next evolutionary phase
happens and you're dealing with Facebook
and Twitter
and uh YouTube right
so anyway
keep going tell us how this uh uh
impacts those okay so kind of bringing
the idea of the publisher distributor
and Association together
um in the 70s there were laws that had
the called the right to respond and
um basically what these laws said is
that if the some media organization says
something bad about you personally you
have a right to to appear in that media
and respond to it
um and so I think the um so these were
challenged
um under the right of Association and
what the courts held and the lead case
was uh Miami Herald case where uh some
political uh actor was you know
criticized and the law that Florida had
said that he had a right to have an
editorial in that newspaper and they
challenged it and the court of the
Supreme Court said no you that's
unconstitutional because a publisher has
a First Amendment right to choose what
views they're they're expressing and
promoting and who they associate with
when they promote those views and
therefore the right to respond laws were
deemed unconstitutional
so
and that comes to what we get with
Section 230 and so section 230 has two
two relevant Provisions in it
and the first is 230 C1 and it states
that no um let me get the exact language
here so I can get it right no provider
or user of an interactive computer
service by social media shall be treated
as a publisher or speaker of any
information provided by another
information content provider so that
that's the first immunity which is
protecting them basically saying you
aren't going to be liable for defamation
that a third-party person speaks you're
not liable for what people say on your
platform yes just because you're hosting
a mix it and so that basically uh
overturns or you know deals with the
Prodigy case that um and makes them all
all of it looks like the CompuServe case
um but the second part is deemed it's a
title is called civil liability and it
says no provider of an interactive
Computer Service shall be held liable on
account of any action voluntarily taken
in good faith to restrict access to or
the availability of material that the
provider or user considers obscene lewd
lascivious filthy excessively violent
harassing or otherwise objectionable
whether or not such material is
constitutionally protected
so this sounds to me like
a dry dull and boring version of
Catch-22
right so in Catch-22 I will remind the
audience Catch 22 is the following
provision
you do not have to fly military missions
if you are crazy but if you don't want
to fly military missions then you're
obviously sane so get up there
um and the line is
that's some catch
Catch-22 it's the best there is and this
section 230 is really catch 230 and it
becomes really diabolical at the point
that you get to the phrase otherwise
objectionable is that the correct that
is certainly um that is certainly one of
the problems that has happened basically
the courts have interpreted otherwise
objectionable to mean anything that the
social media company deems objectionable
if we're interpreting under rules of
statutory interpretation that courts
apply generally what they do is they
look at the other items in the list and
then interpret the open phrase otherwise
objectionable to have a similar
limitation so we'd basically look at
otherwise objectionable would be
something that is related to harassing
violence or obscenity of some sort but
the courts have not taken that route and
they've basically interpreted otherwise
objectionable to mean anything but I
think the the bigger problem in this
statute is
that these two Provisions are not tied
expressly tied together I think that
what the intent was if the intent was to
look at let's basically accept the
argument that Prodigy made which was we
have very limited rules on censorship
they're all laid out and when we engage
in that limited levels of censorship
under these Express rules then we should
still be treated like a distributor and
not be liable for other speech and so if
the Civil liability provision said no
provider or user of interactive Computer
Services shall be held liable as a
publisher on account of the editorial
decisions they make in good faith
then that would be very limited and it
would limit the liability that we or
would limit the immunity from liability
to social media companies if they have
clearly written rules that they're
enforcing in good faith
and if they instead want to have kind of
this freewheeling editorial control then
they'd be treated like a publisher
right and and I can certainly tell you
as somebody who has been thrown off of
platforms has been demonetized on
platforms that these rules are
impossible to follow they are vague and
it would appear that they are vague by
Design to provide discretion for these
platforms to arbitrarily enforce the
rules and
um you know this is
it's it's difficult stuff because
you have to stand in the right place to
see what is what is occurring this pair
of Provisions right section one and
section two or not yeah one and two uh
of section 230.
um basically create a what we would call
in biology a super species that is to
say something with advantages that allow
it to defeat uh all other competitors or
in this case defeat users who wish to
utilize the platforms as a uh as a
distributor right we Face the ruthless
and arbitrary publisher
that wants to Avail itself of the right
to alter what can be said and remove
people who would say things that it
doesn't want said to label things as
misinformation that are actually facts
Etc but it has no liability and we have
no recourse to even point out that the
rules that they have provided are uh so
unclear as to be unfollowable
um so it is that pair of things that
functions uh uh together like a bludgeon
yeah go ahead it was just yeah they're
exercising the full editorial control of
a newspaper publisher but with no risk
of any consequences for what's being
said so they get to they can take steps
that actually shape the message that's
being delivered
um and control it but they have just
zero risk of liability for anything
that's being said and it really is just
um it creates this kind of Beast and I
don't think that was the original intent
because
um the idea of at least if we look at
the two cases that developed and the
type of of censorship that were
editorial control that was being
exercised by Prodigy it was so limited
but as it's written it has just this
blanket liability from any defamation
and then it has this
immunity blanket immunity from
defamation and then this immunity from
censorship now generally and this is why
the right of Association is important to
understand
generally you know the publisher has
that First Amendment right to
um edit and censor you know at their
complete discretion
um and so the Civil immunity in section
two actually doesn't really do that much
um if it's a standalone provision
because they all you already have the
First Amendment right to set edit and
censor in bad faith if you want and
there isn't going to be any liability
um there's it it provides immunity in
very limited situations there's one case
that was recently decided where it was
intentional interference with business
expectancy which is basically bad
bouncing your competition to try and get
them to break a deal or potential deal
with arrival
the immunity here might play it play in
there potentially but as far as um
generally it doesn't provide that much
immunity unless it was keyed to the
ability to get the immunity from
defamation in the first place so
um I'd like to come at this from a
slightly different direction uh
the the problem is you've got to you
know if we step back into the mindset of
1996.
you have an emerging landscape and as
much as these major platforms are
intuitive to us now they were anything
but intuitive to anyone at that point
right I mean the idea of Twitter is
preposterous on its face right you're
going to have a uh a text-based service
in which you're limited to what was it
originally 180 characters right that
doesn't sound like that's going to be a
winner
um but obviously things are different
but here's the problem
in the the world of dial-up and I
believe CompuServe was dial-up uh
initially
you had these services that somebody was
opting into right some service that you
were opting into it was not
um ubiquitous right I did know a couple
of people with CompuServe email
addresses but this was not the place
where the world's business was conducted
and
in that environment the idea the
freedoms to set rules that govern what
takes place in the space uh
are very different than when this is the
de facto Public Square where the the
arbitrary rights of the platform
actually interfere with the
um the de facto rights of the public so
the problem is we are dealing and I I
don't think I've even heard this term
used we are dealing with quasi-public
spaces right and I want to dispense with
the argument that we all hear so
frequently well it's a private company
can do what it wants well it is a
private company however it is managing a
quasi-public space airports are by and
large privately held
if airports decide they want to
arbitrarily decide that you know
Republicans can't fly that's obviously a
problem and you can make the same
argument they're private corporations
they can provide service to whoever they
like
I'm sorry no if you you know if you have
effectively private corporations allowed
to set up a no-fly list
um based on political orientation you
have a serious problem immediately
likewise hospitals often privately held
do you really want hospitals to be able
to refuse service to people I mean we've
seen this actually under covet we've
seen questions about whether or not
um the so-called unvaccinated uh were
entitled to medical treatment and yes I
understand that there's a
um a philosophical question there but
there's also this deeper legal question
which is if you're providing a service
that is necessary for Citizens you are
in a different situation than if you are
engaged in some Niche activity which is
not fundamental to life like the ability
to travel the ability to enter the
Public Square and participate in a
discussion I think that I under
understand the appeal of that argument
the problem that it comes from a legal
standpoint in the first first amendment
standpoint is this right to Association
and your your airport or your hospital
is an example of non-expressive
associational relations and therefore
imposing limitations based on you know
you can't you can't uh restrict first
based on their Viewpoint
um doesn't impact the purpose of that
Association which is to fly somewhere or
to provide medical services but social
media is deemed at an expressive
Association it's media it's like a
newspaper to a certain extent and even
in the the right to respond cases the
argument there was the newspaper has
this huge platform and I can't I as an
individual can't get out to as many
people therefore it's totally unfair
because the newspaper has this huge
platform they can totally change the
conversation and I'm helpless to try and
respond and the courts rejected that
saying that that that's the nature of
the business here this is still an
expressive and and see therefore they
have a right to choose who they
associate with and who they don't
associate with they also know and I a
second problem comes to figuring out how
to draw the fine lines that you know
what type of viewpoint can you not
discriminate against versus what type of
viewpoint you know can you discriminate
against and under the First Amendment
the courts have been really clear that
if we're going to impose liability you
have to have really bright lines and
easy to find lines in place
um or else you end up having a a fear of
chilling so I think that trying to adopt
any law that is based on the Viewpoint
you know prohibiting a Viewpoint
discrimination it becomes very tricky to
do and that's what we've seen in the
Texas law and the Florida law that have
been both been deemed unconstitutional
on the Florida law basically was saying
you can't censor political candidates
and that was deemed to be Viewpoint
based discrimination that was
unconstitutional but they did they did
permit the some of the disclosure
requirements
um the law also required them to
disclose you know the all the rules that
they have for censorship any changes to
those rules and the number of view
counts that you've been getting so you
can try and check track the shadow
Banning and they held that those were
those were you know Viewpoint neutral
rules and therefore and those disclosure
requirements were upheld they did in the
Florida law hold that one of the
disclosure requirements which was a
thorough explanation of why you're being
censored was too burdensome and
therefore was found to be
unconstitutional because of the volume
of censorship that they do it was just
deemed to be would be impractical to
exercise that right but
um so but you can have some type of
limitations as long as their their
Viewpoint neutral they may have a chance
of surviving the First Amendment
challenge
so this again goes to the issue of this
super species right on the one hand I
understand the argument that it is
technically too onerous to require these
platforms to explain every instance of
censorship probably
some you know well above 99 of instances
of censorship are some tiny account
saying something obnoxious and it's
transparent on its face why it's not
being allowed on the other hand
um
when YouTube doesn't have to explain
why it has demonetized our Channel it
does not have to point to the statements
that it finds to be false for example
and then the statements that it clearly
was responding to turn out to be true
obviously it should reverse the decision
right and the fact that these platforms
do not have to be specific about this
stuff means that there is no requirement
of consistency
for them they are not required to behave
logically they can just simply
effectively decide who they don't like
and they can uh you know put a shackle
on and
um this is obviously the result
of an anachronistic law being applied to
Modern circumstances that its authors
did not understand I want to say one
other thing before before we lose it the
argument that it's a private company can
do what it wants it's I understand the
appeal of it too and as much as you know
I'm a died in the wool liberal
Progressive and so that's not a native
argument to me I am concerned about
things like corporate power and good
regulations are uh a necessary feature
of the landscape as I see it however
in 2022 boy do I understand this
argument right my feeling is we have
malignant government and I want its
power minimized because the way it
wields that power is
um is paradoxical and I would just point
out that the argument the classically
libertarian argument it's a private
corporation that can do what it wants
that argument is actually functioning in
the service of aggressive malignant
governance as we've now discovered the
platforms are apparently meeting with
the government and the government is
telling them who it wants censored so
this is a fascist nightmare unfolding on
these platforms hiding behind this
libertarian notion that these are
private corporations they can do what
they want so I think that there's a
couple a couple things to address that
the first the first way that it could be
addressed would be again going back to
tying the immunity from defamation to an
agreement that they only censor in good
faith based on existing written rules
and such because their rules clear rules
and so they are what's happening there
by giving by granting the immunity from
defamation the government is granting a
huge benefit to the social media
companies they could not exist but for
that immunity from liability and so when
government grants someone a benefit they
can exact a price from that and that
price could be to comply with rules on
censorship that and limit your
censorship to good faith censorship
based on pre-written rules provide clear
explanations for that censorship and
such
um and so if we tied section one and two
together
um then that that would be addressed
this by by requiring social media
companies make a choice you can you can
censor freely is in bad faith if you
want but then you don't get the immunity
if you want the immunity you have to
have these clear rules and that was what
when the um under the Trump
Administration the they put forth a huge
proposal on amending section 230 and
this is one of the things that they
propose specifically was tying these
together and having specific rules on if
you want the immunity you have to you
have to have clearly written rules they
have to you have to have an enforcement
mechanism a way to an appeal and
challenge that ruling
um and so it's definitely something that
could be fixed in this that would do
that and it's permissible because we're
providing that benefit it's the
trade-off saying if you want this
immunity from liability you have to do
something and I do think that was the
original intent but I think that would
address this the the super beast that
we've created by saying that you know
they have to have clear rules
um and that we can actually back that up
um I think that the other things that
states can do I think the Florida case
that allowed or you know permitted some
of the disclosure requirements they did
say that the you know thorough
explanation of the censorship was
impermissible but I can imagine lesser
requirements such as you need to quote
the specific language that you say
violates the rules and you need to
identify what that rule is is something
that states may be able to do on an
individual basis
um without amending section 230
um that I think also would go to at
least part of the problem because I do
think I mean one of the biggest
complaints that I hear from a lot of the
the content providers is the we don't
know what the rules are I mean the whole
thing of demonetizing Dark Horse you
know originally that demonetization was
our advertisers are making us but now
that you know I watch my watch your
podcast and they got ads on them yeah
they got ads and they make the money so
obviously YouTube doesn't think that
whatever you're saying is unadworthy
they're just doing it for this whatever
the arbitrary because they don't like
you
um
and I do think that the the even section
230 censorship does talk about good
faith and the courts have not gone too
much into what that actually means
um but um that may be part of the
solution too is trying to get a good
case there that says you know this
censorship wasn't in good faith the one
case that from the ninth circuit that I
mentioned earlier on tortious business
interference with business expectancy
the Court held well if you're trying to
ruin someone's business you aren't
acting in good faith so the immunity
actually didn't protect him in that case
but that's the that's the most on point
case we have and we don't really know
what the good faith means
um otherwise so I do think that we could
address this problem without adopting a
rule that says you can't discriminate
based on viewpoint because I think
that's going to be I mean I don't it's
the first amendment is going to prohibit
that type of limitation
um the Florida was really clever in how
they did it they were trying to say that
well we're doing candidates and
therefore you know we have a an interest
in you know basically if you're
censoring one candidate in a race but
not the other candidate you're
effectively giving a campaign
contribution and we're allowed to adopt
laws on campaign contributions and even
that the Court held was not a good
enough basis to require uh them to carry
out candidates or limit the ability to
censor candidates so it is going to be a
really steep Road
um the second point is that you know the
Justice Thomas on the Supreme Court has
advocated similar to what you were
advocating is we should treat social
media companies like common carriers
um which are you know are required to
take off Commerce and that I mean that
would I think present a different you
know it would re-categorize social media
as something else
um but you know it's um that might work
I think it's it's going to be hard there
was um a case that came out a couple
years ago
um out of New York which was it was a
public broad Public Access channel that
was run by a private entity and the
Supreme Court held that that private
entity had had the First Amendment right
to choose who it you know who gets
channels and who don't and how they
organize it and I think that would
um that logic would apply to social
media companies trying to limit based on
censorship under the common carrier
Theory but um you know that is one of
the other theories that are out there
all right uh there are a number of
points that uh I want to catch up on
here
um one thing I hear missing in what
you've described as necessary and I
think it's implied in what you said but
I want to highlight it is not only clear
rules and an explanation of what you
violated but a process right there has
to be a process and it has to be
transparent right the idea that
um Twitter throws you off because
it claims you violated a rule and then
sometimes it'll say as it did in Jordan
Peterson's case for example or Dr Roller
Gator you have to delete this tweet
which is offensive and by doing so you
are admitting that you violated the
terms of service right and so you know
talk about catch-22s that's that's
exactly what they've set up and there's
no mechanism other than frankly having
your friends shout at them in public you
know to go in and say actually no I
didn't violate the rules or here are you
know 17 examples where you have left the
exact same behavior or something far
more extreme uh live on your servers and
you've singled me out because of who I
am and what I think not because of what
I said right you need to have that
process
I would also point out and I think this
is really
you've got
the authors of section 230 in 1996
understandably and unavoidably failing
to understand how the law they wrote
would work in a future they could not
possibly have foreseen
that's uh that is what it is but what
happens is you now have the federal
government
hiding behind the protections of private
corporations who have this pair of
Provisions that make them into this
unbeatable force a force with all of the
immunities and none of the costs
right and this is reminiscent I would
say of what we discovered
um through
largely through Snowden
right that you know we have a
constitution that protects us from uh
the overreach of our government but
nobody thought to prevent our government
from subcontracting spying on its
citizens to another government right in
other words I'm protected from the
federal government
uh spying on me by Provisions that were
written long before the modern
technological era but I'm not protected
from the British government
spying on me and if the U.S government
says Hey spy on threat to the British
government right this is just unforeseen
right so that five eyes
um you know uh Outsourcing of
obviously unconstitutional activities is
now happening in the context of social
media where the federal government which
is not allowed to censor me is now
telling Twitter and YouTube
um you know here are the people that we
don't want to have access to the world
you have Biden
um stepping onto a blood red stage and
invoking uh clear and present danger
which is uh effectively a thinly veiled
um
uh argument that the censorship is
required
um for the protection of the nation
um and this is uh you know it's a
nightmare and uh so this is not a small
matter that rests on the question of
whether or not section 230 should be two
isolated Provisions that provide
benefits without the obvious cost that
should go with them
um this is this is something on which
the functioning of civilization depends
yeah no I I think you're right and I do
think this is a good time I think maybe
to transition to talk about the cases
that are going on right now or the main
case which is the states of Missouri and
Louisiana suing all the federal agencies
that are involved in the censorship
for this and there is a Doctrine under
the first amendment that recognizes
under certain circumstances when the
government is acting in conjunction with
the private entity to censor speech that
private entities speech and that private
entity censorship does can violate the
First Amendment
and so what the the state of Missouri
and Louisiana are arguing is that the
federal government has
entered some type of partnership with
the social media companies they've
adopted section 230 which gives these
social media companies this massive
power to sensor and then they're working
in conjunction with those companies to
um tell them what to censor and the
courts have recognized a couple ways
that this can happen one of them is when
the government
um you know compels private entities to
engage in censorship and here the the a
recent case dealt with um the NRA in New
York where the NRA was offering these
Insurance packages through private
insurance companies
um that will basically give you some
type of protection if you're sued for
firing your gun and the state regulators
and the governor basically pressured
saying hey we regulate all of you
insurance companies and we're going to
start cracking down on you with our
regulations if you stay in partnership
with the NRA
and therefore they all all the insurance
companies stop working with the NRA and
the Court held that that was an example
of suppressing the NRA's gun advocacy by
pressuring their Partners to not work
with them and therefore that did violate
their the NRA's First Amendment rights
and so that was the the compulsion the
second way that it can happen is if
there's a partnership if the government
enters into a partnership with private
entities to enter into a censorship
regime and that's what the state of
Missouri and Louisiana are arguing and
they're saying so the federal government
has given this great censorship of
section 230 and then are partnering with
these social media companies to tell
them what to censor and they've gotten
through Discovery and through some of
the documents that came out in the
earlier lawsuits by individuals they've
gotten a certain amount of documents
that have shown this level of of
coordination and partnering
and they've gotten past the first hurdle
that they wanted to so they're seeking a
preliminary injunction to basically tell
the government to stop telling social
media companies who to censor and in
order to get that they need Discovery
and so the the the lawsuit faced a first
test and back in July they the lawsuit
got past that test the court basically
said you have enough actual evidence of
this partnership that if we assume it's
all true
um would State the First Amendment
violation so we're going to allow you to
get this discovery and then so they've
gotten a certain level of Discovery than
just yesterday the the Court ruled that
they should be able to get broader
Discovery including people in the White
House announced Anthony fauci and his
Communications with the social media
company so it's worse to come on that
um and so we're really going to be able
to dig into the evidence and see how
deep this partnership runs
and um if it if it is what we think it
is then um that will end up being a
violation of the First Amendment
um yes although I believe that we are
I believe we have the evidence to detect
an arms race of sorts here and I do
think the courts are the most likely
they are the entity the governmental
entity that retains
the most public spiritedness and
Immunity from capture uh such that they
might still be able to function but the
problem really is
if you listen to what is said
no maybe maybe I should step back one
step
the reason that we have the
Constitutional protections that we have
is that the American Founders
having experienced tyranny in their own
time from the crown
understood the Ferocious power of
government and sought to explicitly
limit it to protect citizens
the government
has now in many regards I would argue in
most regards been captured by
private interests
interests that are not public spirited
now the power of government is
tremendous
captured it becomes an asymmetrical
weapon that functions on behalf of its
captors but even worse like a child
engaged in the question of well you know
if you had three wishes what would you
wish for well wish number one I want
more wishes those who have captured this
ferociously powerful entity we call the
government
are not content with the limits placed
on it by the Constitution and so
because the Constitution is understood
not to be a suicide pact that is to say
even the provisions in it are understood
in some contexts to be flexible
they are
using certain terms and tropes to
trigger the removal of ordinary limits
right now this is particularly egregious
in the case of the term terrorism just
like clear and present danger the
invocation of the concept of terrorism
triggers many Post 9 11 Provisions that
effectively unhook constitutional rights
so when the Department of Homeland
Security for example declares that
um there are three kinds of uh terrorism
involved in social media traffic you've
got Miss dis and Mal information
misinformation being errors
disinformation being intentional errors
and Mal information being truth which
causes distrust in government
they are saying something Preposterous
and laughable right truth that causes
you to distrust your government is
Terrorism like I'm not allowed to talk
about the fact that my government has
been captured
um that's obviously nuts
but that's not the important part of it
the fact that it's funny hides the fact
that it also has a legal implication
which is that all sorts of Provisions in
which the executive branch on its own
authority can designate people as
terrorists and that once that has been
done the necessity to defeat terrorists
is so great that we must Avail ourselves
of exotic rights to censor to monitor uh
to Corral Etc that logically uh absurd
chain
means that we don't know what it is that
has been said and frankly the ability
the right of discovery that the court
grants only goes so far once the
executive branch has behind the scenes
said that because so and so said such
and such they are guilty of
malinformation terrorism and are
therefore a threat to the blah blah blah
blah blah once they make that leap even
if a court would laugh at it were that
Court to see it there's no provision
there's no mechanism to know it's
happened you can't challenge it there's
no way to ask a court to review it and
so my basic point and I know this has
been long-winded but my basic point is
they have built a structure where if
they can trigger a certain
um pathway it unhooks all of the normal
protections and there is no way to even
know it's happened so as much as the
courts may be our best hope I'm not
convinced they have access to the
information they would need
yeah no I mean it's certainly the courts
are you know they're they're the weakest
branch of our government they have no
enforcement ability they've got no you
know built-in Financial you know
resources they're entirely dependent on
the other two branches of government for
their support and
um and they also dependent on those two
branches of government acting honestly
and truthfully and if you look in the
cases
um you can find many an example of where
the government has not been truthful to
the court and um you know and it's in
the terrorism context there's you know
you'll find there's a one one particular
case that I've read that was dealing
with the the Department of Justice was
investigating potential terrorists and
they just lied about the existence of
certain records and they tried to argue
to the court that these documents were
so secret they had to lie to the court
and they got caught of course
um and the court wasn't having it but
it's an example of that trying to be
attempted and you have to imagine and
that's going to be happening in other
situations as well I think that when you
have in the social media context we do
have the advantage of the outside
private companies are also involved and
so the federal government doesn't have
complete control of you know if it's an
email between a government and a private
entity there's two copies of that email
and so I think that there's a greater
chance of uncovering at least the
collusion on the censorship here
um on that basis
um you know but it's uh you know it's
always a risk that the government's
going to do and they certainly use the
terrorism scare as justifications for
lots of secrecy and they'll continue to
use it I think that if we look at the
precedent going back in this in the 60s
and 70s on the then the courts were were
facing you know a lot of social upheaval
and the federal government thinking that
they needed secrecy and the courts you
know stood up pretty well against it the
clear and present danger standard is a
pretty high standard for when speech can
be limited it's got to be you know it's
got to be a an immediate Call to Arms in
front of a body that is volatile and can
actually you know create this type of
problems
um and the courts have been pretty you
know that's fairly limited and when it
actually can apply and it's certainly
never going to apply if the precedent is
applied it would never apply to
Something in written form on a social
media uh because that doesn't have the
immediate imminency that the courts in
the past have required before you can
censor that type of speech permissively
wow but this I mean I don't want to get
stuck down this particular rabbit hole
but
again my point would be when it comes to
the post 911
anti-terrorism Provisions the problem is
that a court has to see a case and if
the executive effectively comes up with
a rationale whereby through its own
reading of the law
these instances do not
they cannot be shared with a court then
the fact that a court would say that's
absurd you have to share it with the
court doesn't matter because what you
effectively have is the executive branch
having freed itself from checks and
balances because terrorism is so darn
dangerous and you know so
you know when I hear
in a context where I'm involved right I
am discussing as a biologist the truth
of covid of the various treatments
available in public and then I hear the
Department of Homeland Security saying
that even true things that you say in
public may be terrorism I know why
they're doing that they're not doing
that because they don't realize how
insane that sounds they're doing it
because
it triggers something internal to this
system which involves it not being
accountable to a court it also triggers
something in the public and I think that
this is where we get this horrid
feedback loop with social media
censorship in that um you know the one
tool that we the public has against this
type of you know government secrecy and
the government that's not willing to
play by the rules is supposed to be the
fourth Branch the media that's supposed
to be exposing it but when you have the
media working hand in hand with the
government on and they're all on the
same page on what message they want
getting out there it makes it so much
harder to get that message out there and
social media was supposed to be a great
you know equalizer because you know we
the people
um are the content providers and you saw
this in the election of trump and
um where social media was able to get
past the big mainstream media barriers
and then they crack down since that and
we've had this massive social media
media censorship campaign ever since and
um and so how do we you know counteract
these these type of things and obviously
terrorism still does trigger something
in people
um so the it makes it that much harder
to get through using whatever media that
is free enough to actually have have
views expressed openly
um so yeah it is we are in a real
quandary it's a real problem right now
um and it's the courts you know have the
potential of a role with this Missouri
suit to
um you know uh really dig into a real
problem and hopefully you know we saw
um it break in the 70s when you had the
church hearings and such there was we
actually got to really dig into a lot of
the the secrecy from the CIA and the FBI
and all that was going on there
um at least partially dug into it
um you know maybe this this love this
lawsuit has the potential to have that
type of break where we see how open the
collusion has been between the
government and the you know on the
social media companies on censorship but
you know it's um we'll see how far it
gets
um and it's you know there's only so
much they can do and as long as the the
public the media that the majority of
the public digests is
uh so willing to go along with the
federal government's line it's going to
be hard to break that open as well
um but it's all the more important for
different voices out there and as long
as there's at least demonetized or not
voices like Dark Horse and and um such
they can get that the opposite views out
there there somehow but
well uh I would also I think I want to
go back I invoked fascism earlier when I
was talking about uh the collusion
between the federal government and these
private entities to censor and I want I
want to
um I'm sure that sounded like hyperbole
to some but I want to point out just how
frightening you know the sin Quan non of
fascism is the hybrid between corporate
and governmental power
and the it always comes with the
demonization of minorities
um and in this case you have I think the
partnership is different than it's ever
been this is a historically novel
version of fascism but not only do you
have the federal government
meeting with platforms and giving them
uh guidance on who it wants censored but
you also have uh the power of these
corporations to shut down would-be
competitors so if the argument is well
you can't use Twitter because Twitter
has the right to throw you off and then
the answer is well okay then I'll use
parlor well no you won't use parlor
because parlor is depending on an
architecture that that we control and so
the point is
Twitter would be insane to cannibalize
its own business by throwing people off
so that basically a there was a large
population that needed to go somewhere
else and be
um that it became an uninteresting
platform because it was just a single
big Echo chamber right on the other hand
in the context where you can't create
that alternative service because if you
do create it and it becomes wildly
popular it will be shut down then the
point is oh well Twitter now has an
anti-competitive advantage it is it is
uh it not only does it have the uh
freedoms of a publisher and the rights
of a platform simultaneously but it also
has uh the ability to create an
absolutely gargantuan barrier to entry
for a competitor who would take
advantage of the insanity of Twitter and
so
um that combination of things is this
few Fusion of governmental power and
private corporate power together in one
entity that is now in doing many of the
things that are classically involved in
fascism it is
um censoring it is punishing in uh extra
judicial ways
um and it is basically designating
minorities who are not deserving of the
protections that citizens ordinarily
have so at what point do you have enough
circumstantial evidence that something
that
an objective Observer would call fascism
is apparently alive and well in in the
United States in 2022 at what point do
you have enough evidence to say holy
moly it's happening here
well I mean and that's the question is
you know who who can do something with
that and you know at a certain point
we've talked about you know the limits
of the courts but that the courts have
some ability in in addressing that
um but you know it's really a matter of
public opinion and you know it's and
given that the collusion is between the
media and the government trying to sway
public opinion is particularly difficult
I mean just the absurdity that fact
Checkers treat statements by the
government as the the truth when they're
deciding what's true and not I mean I
can't think of anything that is just
more insane than that and the whole
point of media is to check the
government so to take the government's
word
um is just uh it's kind of mind-blowing
and it shows how warped our current
media environment is right now
um and and the your fascism point the
fact that there's this such reverence
for government is
um you know it's it's very novel right
now
um in a novel way but it certainly uh
shows that that conjunction between
government and private entities that we
should be concerned about yep and it
also uh you know just you could you
could spend all day spotting the little
um asymmetries and arbitrary forms of
power but the ability to throw people
off social media on the basis that what
they are saying is so dangerous that it
cannot be allowed obviously creates a
mechanism
whereby they can construct a pretense of
consensus where there is no consensus
whatsoever so the basic point is well
how do you know that that statement is
dangerous and the answer is because all
the experts agree well what happens when
you throw off anybody who says I don't
agree is you get all the people who
agree so it looks like a consensus and
that then creates a
a false justification
for continuing with an even more
aggressive policy so you keep seeing
that we saw that with the hunter Biden
laptop we saw that with you know the
lably theory the efficiency of masking
and shutdowns and then we saw in the
2020 election things I mean the fact uh
safe and effective vaccines yeah and
then vaccines and it's I mean if you
look at the on the election context just
abstractly you know the the almost
immediate demonization of anyone wanting
to challenge the validity of Elections I
mean if you can't if you don't have a an
absolute free right to challenge the to
allege an election is corrupt you're
going to get corrupt elections I mean
that is the only protection against that
type of corruption is the ability to
call it out and so but when you have
this you know the the this very quick
you know agreement in the media that
it's all bogus
um you know it undermines that and that
gets to the core of our you know of our
whole governmental system is the ability
to challenge elections and then
obviously in the vaccines I mean the
safety of of our our lives and just the
pressure that's been put on vaccines I
mean uh you know it's just like a month
or two ago I saw something in my grocery
store of a uh it was a cardboard cut out
of a kid and a superhero outfit saying
you know I got my vaccine I'm you know
once they approved it for five-year-olds
or whatever I mean just the the idea
that it can't be you can't challenge
that type of thing it's really
yes even where the challenges are wrong
they are fundamental right it is the
fact that it is challenged and it stands
up to challenge that tells you that it
was uh that it was
free and fair or close to it
um and you know we know that hey we know
two things one both sides challenge the
fairness of Elections when they lose
right that's an unfortunate fact I don't
want to live in that country but that's
the country we live in right the
Democrats did not treat the Trump
election as free and fair they demonized
uh it as Downstream of a Russian
campaign to sway the election remember
2000 and 2004 too they're both you know
you had Congress members challenging the
the Electoral count
um in Congress
um as well it was just it's happened a
lot it's happened a lot and so the point
is that's the world we live in and we
have to accept it not you know cherry
pick and look at one side as you know
crying foul when it loses the fact is we
have a crisis of confidence in our
electoral system and you know I think
frankly we rightly so I think there's a
lot at stake in elections and we are
told that you know it's an existential
threat to the nation if you know the
other side wins frankly we're told that
no matter who the enemy is Right Mitt
Romney was you know the reason that we
couldn't engage in discussing a third
party option you know and then it became
Trump and people don't remember that
that's just that's always the argument
remember the demonetization of Obama as
well I mean both sides do it it's they
you know it's it's it's just part of the
nature of what it is we're going to have
both sides demonizing the other side and
that's why you need to have you know a
more detached way of looking at election
challenges that um doesn't tie in does
it doesn't turn on who it is it's
supposed to be a process that's there
and it needs to be explored and not you
know immediately demonized it's um right
and the and as you point out I like your
formulation a lot that if you forbid the
challenge that then you enable
the
Distortion right you enable collusion to
to affect these elections and frankly
the hunter Biden laptop story which
I remember being demonized for saying
hey this is serious and important and it
does involve the president because what
Biden was talking about was influence
pedaling which is was clearly clearly
something that Biden had engaged in uh
over his career and then you also get
the the blackmail ability I mean once
once someone engages and once they allow
themselves to be bribed they then can be
blackmailed it's um a big deal right but
the point is the suppression of that
story
um was an attempt by whoever did it to
sway an election right it's newsworthy
information that that laptop exists it
was clear at the time that it where it
was fairly clear at the time that it
wasn't phony
um and yeah its emergence was
unfortunate for team blue but I guess
the point would be hey how about
nominating people who don't have this
kind of [ __ ] in their background right
um so uh
the you know when you make it impossible
to discuss conspiracy you are giving a
gift to those who would conspire that's
the that's the point and uh when you
make it impossible to discuss
um the corruption of an election you
make it possible to corrupt elections
and I don't know that that principle a
principle must have a name and I I don't
happen to know what it is but if you
don't want to see the thing you need the
process in which we can explore whether
it has taken place and as soon as you
start forbidding it you are guaranteeing
that's that's the point
yeah no I mean and I think that that we
those who want to
um you know permit this type of
suppression
um you know argue well you know people
are so easily tricked by lies I think we
discount the power of Truth to
um you know eventually climb its way to
the top and you know I think that you
know however convincing a false argument
is
um you know it's much better to allow
the truth to dispel it as opposed to
just try and suppress it
um well I mean you know they they have a
nasty habit of telling you exactly what
they're doing and then saying the
opposite of the truth and the fact is
yes getting to the truth is a messy
process but the truth does tend to out
in a Level Playing Field and the problem
is not that people are so easily
persuaded by lies that's certainly true
in the immediate right but in the long
term I mean look at what happened with
dark horse
we discussed a lot of things that were
apparent if you had a biologically
sophisticated perspective
and people heard it and the point was
they had to Avail themselves YouTube had
to Avail itself of
extraordinary rights in order to prevent
that information from spreading and you
know demonetizing us was clearly a
threat to our economic well-being
designed to persuade us to stop talking
about certain things
um but it didn't work and so now they've
resorted you know our numbers despite
the fact that it is evident to us when
we walk around in the world
that we are reaching a large number of
people our numbers do not reflect it and
this is something people who do not have
a large channel will not Intuit but it
is very apparent when you are being uh
Shadow banned uh or otherwise having the
information about your channel altered
it you feel it right you feel the
numbers go suddenly flat and
um you know when you talk about it it
sounds like uh you're being petty right
or you're imagining things because you
think you're reaching more people than
you are but it's not subtle when it's
targeted at you I don't even think it's
designed to be subtle I think it is
designed to create a sense of futility
and
um you know one has to ignore it but the
power of these entities is so
asymmetrical right you just yeah this is
one area where I think that states might
be able to address this again going back
to the Florida lawsuit and the
disclosure requirements under the the
case holding that proved some of the
disclosure requirements
um I think you could make a good
argument that states could adopt laws
that require you to provide notice when
you're doing any type of censorship and
basically Outlaw Shadow Banning because
I do think Shadow Banning is the most
nefarious I mean it's secret censorship
it's the most nefarious form of
censorship and
um you know and I don't think you can
say you're doing it in good faith if
you're doing it secretly and therefore I
think that section 230 does permit
states to enact certain laws that aren't
inconsistent with it and the Florida
lawsuit shows that some of those
disclosure requirements can survive a
challenge
um and uh before the law did not have a
specific prohibition on Shadow Banning
but
um it got to the requirement of view
counts so people could at least observe
it but I think the uh I think you can
probably go a little further on that and
States could prohibit Shadow Banning
because I do think that that is such a
nefarious thing when you don't know
what's happening and limiting the reach
and not allowing the true organic breach
and you see this on channels like yours
I know a Jimmy dors pointed this out a
whole bunch on how you know he gets
great view counts he was growing and
growing and then just hits a plateau and
stops growing yep no it's exactly what
it looks like our numbers have been flat
for half a year or more it's it's
shocking how
[Music]
um
how clear it is that some new Force has
been applied
um but I like your idea of States
addressing this and I would point out
there are numerous examples where
because of the globalized nature of our
system a single state or a single nation
in the case of larger issues enacting
wise regulation can often force the
issue right California
forced emissions regulations that I mean
they were necessary I grew up in LA and
my God the air was disgusting and the
fact is California enacted some
regulations which yes people still
Grumble about but wow the quality of
life that uh improvements that came from
that were spectacular and the fact is
you know California had a big car market
so you'd be crazy to make a car that
couldn't be sold in California so people
just you know lived by the standard even
where they didn't have to
um in the case of you know do you really
want to have a social media platform
that you you can't watch in Texas no so
you know that means the ability is there
once you require social media companies
to build the infrastructure to meet
those obligations even if it's for one
state it's easily scalable so it's it's
not a bigger burden on social media
companies either
um as far as the you know the
infrastructure to do it if you get a
couple States like Florida and Texas and
act something like that that's going to
be you know those two big states are
going to be enough to you know I think
probably tip the balance on it
um
you know we'll see obviously courts will
you know we just have one Court ruling
it's a you know a pellet decision so
it's good in that sense but
um you know courts may look at them
differently different courts but I think
it's at least a good start and it's an
area and because the the 230 does
specifically allow state regulations
that are not inconsistent
um it's it's definitely a possible
Avenue to try and at least get to one of
the problems and I think Shadow Banning
I do think if we could end Shadow
Banning
um that would um
you know I think that would go far
because you know one of the things about
you know when they have to censor openly
there's you know the um the Barbra
Streisand effect of you know once you
know it's being censored everybody wants
to see it and
um you know I think the uh I think that
that would uh at least a little step in
the right direction
um that doesn't actually require
amending section 230 because I think
trying to amend section 230 at this
point is um is is too hard without
Congress is right now obviously they
can't do anything that's controversial
so
well uh I do think that uh I have a
principle I like which is uh read the
books they seek to burn
um and I think in this environment given
what's the foot we have an obligation of
citizens to do this and you know some of
that stuff may be garbage but in that
garbage there's going to be the things
you need to know and you should
um pursue them
yeah it's um one of the things that I
thought that's always weird is the um
you know the a lot of conspiracy
theories get demonized
um and suppressed but then the whole
Flat Earth conspiracy theory was seemed
to be amazingly promoted
um and so it's just uh made me think
it's you know less valuable because no
one's trying to suppress it it was so
ridiculous that nobody wanted bothered
to suppress it
um yeah it's an odd one because it you
can demonstrate to yourself
the Earth can't be flat
um so I I do wonder why it suddenly
showed up but
but nonetheless
um you know
here we are on a very round earth yeah
well there's no effort to suppress it
you know when you've got the Ancient
Aliens is you know promoted again
something nobody bothers to suppress
um and that's the the flip side of read
the books they want to burn
um also look at what they don't care
about and compare compare it yeah I
would agree
um oh one last point I wanted to make
and then anything that you think uh
should be on the table here we'll go
with that but the part of the Shadow
Banning issue that you know it's
uncomfortable to talk about
um
Heather and I ended up
doing what we've done
we scrambled when uh our
successful very successful run as
professors came to a sudden end as a
result of lunacy
um and so we ended up accidentally
becoming
you know something else in the world
including podcasters and then that got
ended by a kind of not ended but it got
demonetized uh by a related kind of
lunacy
um but what people I think don't really
into it
is how directly this Shadow Banning and
all of its analog is impacts
ones
uh
Security in the world and one's ability
to earn right in other words you can
look at the numbers of subscribers and
the fact that it's gone flat and say
well okay I don't know what to make of
that but all right so how many neighbors
do you actually need on the other hand
there are two points here one is if
we're saying things that are important
in the conversation
limiting our reach artificially
um
basically means that uh we don't have
whatever our natural impact in the world
would be but it also means that our
ability to
um you know
uh to make our way in the world is
severely impacted right and we will
never know how severely impacted it is
without you know we would have to sue
Google in order to get Discovery to find
out
um how severely they had been uh
altering our view counts and you know
and they had changed our
um our access to an audience right so
that's the point is there the barrier to
finding out even how badly you've been
impacted is is tremendously large
well it's just contrary to every all all
of the values we look at in this country
the first amendment is supposed to
protect the marketplace of ideas and
just American value of if you get out
there and hustle hard you know your fate
is in your own hands to a certain extent
and you know if you work your best
you're going to make it is a general
belief and Shadow Banning totally goes
against this I mean we saw when you guys
were you know what happened at Evergreen
well that created a bunch of media in it
it gave you a new platform a new ability
to promote yourself to a wider audience
and so that's the marketplace of ideas
in effect working properly
um but Shadow Banning because it's
secret because you can't see it it's
just so contrary to its it says that you
know as hard as you gonna work we're
gonna hold you back in the secret way
and you aren't going to be able to get
there it's like the you know the type of
things that at least we imagine happened
in the South as far as Whispering of oh
this person is too friendly to the
minorities so we're not going to go to
their business and stuff it's that uh
you know hidden in secret
you know unfair inherently unfair
limitations
um and it's just so contrary to
everything and I think um if we could
address it in a way
um it would I think it would be at least
a step in the right direction and I
certainly think it's the most nefarious
aspect of censorship that's going on
yeah well I mean these things are bad
enough when it's a whisper campaign uh
but
a whisper campaign is one thing a
corporate government secret hybrid is
quite another and really
um we have to be incredibly careful not
to burn out the claim people will just
get used to hearing what this implies
and they will stop paying attention but
when this happens in history what comes
next uh
is historic tragedy and
um this is the moment to avoid the
historic Tragedy by recognizing that uh
it's not going to Goose step this this
time right it learned the lesson who's
stepping is out but the tropes they're
there
you know no it's it's it's it's
something that cannot be it should not
be ignored
um you know the first amendment protects
everybody to use it you're supposed to
protect the least popular views with it
and it always comes around I mean it may
be that you know certain people can
think they have comfort
um in you know because their side is not
being censored as much as the other side
but it'll all come around once once that
power is is once you lose your first
amendment rights everybody is going to
suffer from it
um so I think it's you know everybody
needs to recognize that you know threats
I mean if you look at the censorship in
the the 2020 election cycle I mean you
know if if if if there was Shadow
Banning of uh the Trump's you know uh
pro-trump stuff you know that's clearly
Swang an election that's you know that's
you know it sure certainly looks like
you know campaign contribution type
activity
um you know but that once you permit
that then that could be used to suppress
your candidate next time I mean nobody
should be taking comfort in just because
they don't like the people who are being
censored
um yeah I mean it's almost too easy
had they been censoring things that were
truly wrong
this would still be a disastrous
dangerous signal the fact that what they
censored has so quickly been Vindicated
right says not only is it wrong to
censor wrong and dangerous but these
people cannot be trusted to even decide
what's good and what's bad they're
censoring actual information and they're
promoting misinformation and you know
that's whatever process has created that
inversion is not on your side yeah and
it may be I mean it may be that covet
ends up God forbid being a catalyst for
real change if if the vaccines end up
being as dangerous as some fear you know
in the long run maybe that'll be a
catalyst to get people because I think
censorship played such a massive role in
the promotion of the vaccines
yes but it also it's a double-edged
sword because to the extent that these
things are at the very least far more
dangerous than we were led to believe in
the first place and the information that
suggested that they were at least
extremely risky because that information
did exist the incentive for them to
continue to censor the discovery of the
truth
oh yeah I mean it's through the roof and
it's just that's why depending on how
dangerous they end up actually being I
think there's a breaking point where
they only can suppress it so much I mean
if you can get anybody to watch you know
just a real of all of the young athletes
who've died on pitches you know in the
middle of games or whatever
um uh shortly after getting the vaccine
you know you see a certain number of
those and it starts to be hard to ignore
um obviously we aren't there yet and I'm
not saying that those are necessary
caused by the vaccine or not but I'm
just trying to say that I can imagine a
a a level of evidence that becomes too
hard to suppress yes on the other hand
what I fear is that although you
couldn't suppress the pattern on its own
if you
um
falsely portray the pattern uh you
punish and economically [ __ ] anyone
who points out that that's what's
happening the point is let's put it this
way from the Nixon era we got the I
believe it's from the next scenario we
got the term plausible deniability
what we now have is implausible
deniability it doesn't have to be
plausible it just has to be forceful
enough that most people know not to
touch it and I worry that the number of
individual tools that have come together
at the disposal of one
uh
ideology is so powerful that we we have
to realize that those tools are not only
being used against the fundamental
truths but they're being used against
the process that would normally reveal
it yeah no I mean it's it's it's
definitely it's an uphill battle
um and that's why I
you know I'm not hoping that that ends
up being this bad but I do know that
once somebody gets touched by the harm
of it then they they can't be you know
they're much harder to brainwash if you
look at you know all of the the former
you know or not former but people on the
left who have seen the um you know the
harms of wokeness and such you know
because they've been touched by it like
you you as an example you were touched
by it and then now you you you're immune
from that level of brainwashing I think
you know the more people have a personal
experience with tragedy from the harms
from the vaccine
um the more people will be immune from
this type of stuff and it's gonna have
you know if if it gets bad enough God
forbid
um it'll hit a Breaking Point yeah and
we we do see uh people you know whatever
they're willing to say people are not
lining up to uh get inoculated
sure did
all right is there anything else you
believe should be on the table in this
conversation
I'm sure there is but not that I'm
thinking of I think um I just I think
the point in looking at section 230
um I do think that there are things
obviously it could be amended itself but
I really want to reiterate the point
that states can potentially have a role
on disclosure of the censorship and
um and that can I think be at least a
step in the right direction on this that
doesn't have the same impacts on First
Amendment rights and uh it doesn't
conflict with what section 230 gives I
think the second point is just you know
remembering that section 230 is giving
such a huge Boon to these private
companies and so more libertarian-minded
saying these are just private companies
well these are private companies that
are giving a mat getting a massive
government benefit in the form of this
immunity and so asking those companies
to then give a little back in exchange
for this massive government supplement
um is not contrary to libertarian
principles on on their face I think that
um you know it's uh you know it's
definitely when you're giving a
government benefit you can ask for
something back just you know if you want
to be truly libertarian get rid of the
government benefit
um and then we won't have social media
but we won't have this problem either
yeah I think I think those are excellent
points I mean there's a tremendous
precedent for we we are granting access
to something and protection that the
government is facilitating the
possibility for these platforms to exist
and it is entitled uh to ask something
uh in return and it should be doing that
if it was acting in our interest it
certainly would I love your point that
although the right thing to do is to
amend section 230 to link the two
provisions and provide a process and uh
a description of the requirements that
would connect the benefits that these
platforms get to the obligations that
they should naturally have
um but that that may be impractical for
political reasons but what is not
necessarily impractical at the moment is
that uh States could act and impose a
reasonable balance on their own and
courts could bring it about
um that's that's a hopeful message and I
uh I I hope it does occur
sounds good all right well Ramsey
rammerman thank you so much for joining
me where can people find you they can
find you at Ramsey rammerman on Twitter
yeah yeah Adam Ramsey rammerman just my
full name is the best place to find me
um right by the way kudos to your
parents uh for for creating that name
it's it's excellent
um I'm always happy they were debating
between Ramsay and Roscoe and for anyone
at my age The Dukes of Hazzard I would
have I'm much happier yeah Ramsay Ramsey
rammerman Works Roscoe after the Dukes
of Hazzard thing kind of died down that
would have been all right but you would
have had it I think a tough decade there
so
um yeah all right so at Ramsey rammermen
on Twitter and uh we'll have to have you
back as things develop on Section 230 as
they clearly are doing so anyway uh we
will keep the audience posted all right
be well everyone
[Music]
foreign
[Music]